shrek forever after ok so once again
shrek is on another adventure and once
again you're gonna have to shell out
three bucks more ticket for 3d I do
admit though 3d looked really good in
this movie and in holding with
time-honored tradition shrek forever
after relies heavily on piss and fart
jokes at least at first and then kind of
drops that and then kind of gets you
know better
so as for shrek he's settled down into
the family life as we saw at the end of
shrek 3 and now he's missing all that
freedom and happiness that only comes
with being single so shrek wants one day
to feel like a real ogre again and
Rumplestiltskin he promises to give that
to him and then tricks him into a
reality in which he never existed him
from there it's kind of like it's a
wonderful life with Shrek and now
without shrek everything has changed
Rumplestiltskin's ruling the land and no
one has ever even heard of shrek I mean
when shrek first came out shrek was like
a breath of fresh air all poking fun at
the fairy tales that we all knew and
loved that was awesome but now that new
car smell feeling is kind of run out and
it just feels kind of dry I mean Shrek
felt complete as a trilogy but now it
just kind of feels like the Saw movies
like they're just pumping out a sequel
just for the sake of doing it like it
was just like alright the shrek trilogy
is complete it is done uh sir Shrek
still makes money what damn it I mean
well good um
alright uh what to do um uh we'll just
force a sequel how about that will make
Shrek four I guess yeah we'll do that
we'll make it try to feel a jet though
but make it forcefully tie into the
first movie that yeah alright yeah do
that
cool and there you go so I mean if
you've never seen the Shrek movie I'd
say don't even bother with this movie
half the fun of this movie is seeing how
the characters are different in this
reality than they were in the other
movies and if you haven't seen a Shrek
movie don't even bother
there is officially no point now
Rumpelstiltskin has the villain he was
an awesome villain I'll give the movie
that and the Pied Piper makes an
appearance I thought he was cool be it a
little creepy because who better to have
in a kid's movie than the Pied Piper a
fairytale character based off a real guy
who swindled parents into giving him
their kids so we can travel
cross-country with the kids so they can
all freeze to death and die if that's
your dose of the real story of the Pied
Piper that's right nothing but reality
on this channel folks now there are
genuinely a few laughs in this movie and
a couple of touching moments but this
kind of feels like Shrek The Lost
episodes or Shrek the extra adventures
your Shrek collection will feel complete
as a trilogy
you don't need to make it a quadrilogy
is that the right term Claude trilogy so
of the four Shrek movies this is number
four it's last but if you have kids it's
not going to matter what I say I'm here
because they're going to want to see it
and you're going to take them to see it
because what little Timmy wants little
Timmy gets but as you're forced by your
children at gunpoint to go watch this
movie and you slowly realize that the
one who wears the pants in the
relationship isn't the guy or the girl
it's actually the kids like I said
expect a couple laughs a touching moment
but nothing really new except
Rumpelstiltskin in the Pied Piper they
were awesome and if you like this video
and you want to see more then click here
to see more